good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching sky news breakfast now
it's one of the biggest problems posed
by the pandemic how do school children
catch up well the government's revealed
its plan
but it's already under attack we'll talk
to the education
secretary and the shadow education
secretary on the program today
also for you this morning the travel
industry turns up the heat on the
transport secretary to open up more
european destinations for summer
holidays
the ryanair chief executive michael
o'leary joins us
at half past eight and don't you wish
your girlfriend
we'll talk to pussycat dole kimberly
wyatt at half past nine
about a new campaign to take on the
culture of
fast fashion it's wednesday the 2nd of
june
on the ropes the government plans to
help children catch up post pandemic had
criticized
as they stop short of extending the
school day
after uh building so much expectation
around an education recovery plan
coming over the hill then this really
has landed like a damn scrim
transferred by golf buggy first footage
of the tory grande's daughter-in-law
charged over the shooting of a police
superintendent in belize
a vaccine summit to tackle
misinformation as political pressure
grows to ease restrictions in june
after zero covered deaths reported
yesterday
training for the resistance we talked to
myanmar's police defectors who tell us
they had a
shoot to kill policy and under threat
the species in trouble because of
climate change
[Music]
a very good morning to you plans to help
school children
catch up after the pandemic have been
revealed but they're already under fire
this morning
unions have called them a damp squib
that let down the nation's school
children
whitehall sources say plans to add half
an hour to the school day were postponed
following a row over the cost
the government's package amounts to 1.4
billion
pounds it will provide a hundred million
hours of free tuition
our chief political correspondent john
craig reports
it may be half term this week but these
children could soon be catching up on
lost lessons
due to the pandemic with extra tuition
under a 1.4 billion pound covered rescue
plan
being unveiled by the government today
but here in akron in lancashire
in a red wall constituency that turned
blue at the general election
teachers and parents are skeptical it's
got to be a balance between the two
there shouldn't be a rush to kind of
tuition tuition tuition to get them up
to where they need to be
it needs to be more of a holistic
understanding of what the child needs
under the plan
older students will be able to repeat
their final year
but a move to extend the school day by
half an hour
has been postponed it's claimed because
of a whitehall row over the cost
it's quite hard because with my kids
they'd go musk as well so
after school they got moss so with extra
hours they'll make it to
i think it'll be too long announcing the
recovery plan boris johnson
said this next step in our long-term
catch-up plan
should give parents confidence that
we'll do everything we can
to support children who've fallen behind
the education secretary says the plan
for the three t's
extra time teaching and tutoring will
boost children's learning
after the pandemic but teaching unions
claim the funding
is inadequate after so many big words
about not letting any
child be left behind and after uh
building so much expectation around an
education recovery plan
coming over the hill then this really
has landed like a damn script
[Applause]
at this boxing club in walthamstow east
london
teenagers admit the pandemic has
delivered a blow to their studies over
the past year
when i studied behind the screen it was
difficult for me to compare it to study
as a person i get more
uh you know i can learn more when i'm
like you know
talk to you personally in the class but
behind the screen is sometimes
difficult we haven't learned nearly as
much as we would we lost about half of
the year
to a lockdown and even more like maybe
three quarters
so these youngsters at least hoping the
government's tuition catch-up plan
will be a knockout john craig sky news
well let's talk to the education
secretary gavin williamson good to see
you this morning look 1.4 billion pounds
you're putting into this it sounds like
a lot of money
on the offset but you're not spending
the money that the experts say you
should
why not
well it is a lot of money and it builds
on 1.7 billion pounds that we've already
committed
in terms of actually delivering for
children is an extra 100 million hours
of tutoring for children
is making sure that uh that children who
need that help that need that support
we're delivering that tutoring
revolution
to help them get it but we recognize
that it's part of a process as we've
as i just said over the last 12 months
we've already announced a previous 1.7
billion pounds worth of additional
funding and we're looking at a whole
raft of additional ideas
of how we can continue support our
children
making sure none of them are left behind
yeah but i mean you you had
you appointed a catch-up tsar and that
catch-up czar says
you need 15 billion pounds
well what we've been doing is working
very closely with
sir kevin collins and actually the
interventions around
tutoring the interventions about driving
up teacher quality
these are very much built on the work
that we've been doing together
recognizing how incredibly important it
is
that we take on these interventions in
order to be able to help children
that's what we're doing you know for so
long we've known that
tutoring is a real benefit for children
but sadly it's often been for preserve
of
uh those who have that little bit more
wealthy
what we're doing is we're expanding it
out so children
right across the country are able to
benefit up to
six million children benefiting from
this tutoring regime
but also making it simpler and easier
for schools to be able to
access and to use this is going to
deliver
such a revolution in terms of teaching
and
having gone to schools and spoken to
children who are already benefiting from
it
they're seeing the difference children
are seeing the difference
parents are seeing the difference and i
believe teachers are also seeing the
difference that's why
it's right we continue to build on that
success but
sir kevin collins says more will be
needed to meet the scale of the
challenge he's effectively saying in
that
you haven't done enough
and what we all recognize and what i
would say is we
do forgive me is it is it to be done
is is he right would you have liked to
have put more money into this if you
had free reign to do so
what i was just saying is that we
recognize that this is part of a process
uh
just a few months ago just three months
ago we were announcing an extra 700
million pounds worth of
catch up to support children not just
over the summer period
but going into the next year just a few
months before that we're announcing a
further 1 billion pounds
and this is very much part of a process
continuing to build on the success
of the initiatives that are already
working in schools
we're making sure that we build on them
we expand them
so that more children are able to
benefit so yes we're very much looking
as to
how we can continue to build on that
yeah forgive me but but
how is this part of a process because
the the children involved here
i mean depending on where they are
within the the
the academic process but a lot of them
don't have time for this to be built up
this needs to be dealt with immediately
for
those older children in particular
well that's why we've taken the measures
we have done today of announcing
uh 1.4 billion pounds extra recognizing
their interventions that we want to see
put in place straight into the next
academic year
that's why we announced the previous 1.7
billion pounds because we recognized
we wanted to get schools moving forward
on this
longer term we do though want to see
further changes and further improvements
that's why we're doing a review in terms
of uh
time within schools how best we can use
it
and i think there's a debate to be had
as to
whether children should be exiting the
school gated
as they do in some schools at 2 45 or
whether they should be
in school later have we condensed down
the
have we condensed down the lunch time
used to be an hour sometimes in schools
it's half an hour
it's right that we work with schools and
teachers
as well as parents and children as to
what delivers them the best benefits
but you're right there are some children
in their academic career that are coming
close to the end of their academic life
that's why we're offering the
option of a repeat year so those
children who don't think that they've
been able to get the very best out
of their education as a result of a
pandemic are able to repeat it these are
actions recognizing the fact that
there is an urgency there and that's why
we committed
over three billion pounds worth of
investment
to supporting children with a
recognition that more
needs to be done but i mean you
appointed
sir sir kevin collins as the catch-up
czar i mean
do you trust him do you agree with him
so so we've been working incredibly
closely at all stages
that's that's a very straightforward
question do you trust him
do you believe in what he's trying to
achieve
yes or no absolutely and these are why
the interventions
he says you need 15 billion pounds
you've given him 1.4 in this 1.7 earlier
on as you say
but he says you need 15 billion if you
trust him if you
absolutely agree with him why isn't he
getting that money
so what we've been doing is working with
sir kevin on a whole package of measures
one of those is the expansion of our
tutoring program
there's a billion pounds going into that
the other key element of
uh that expansion and sort of support
for schools and children
is actually through teacher quality as
well that's why we're committing
400 million pounds to early years and
driving up teacher quality
because actually these are interventions
that we've worked on together
and actually this is why we're
organizing a review in terms of time
in terms of how we look at expanding
time
what is best for schools but most
importantly
what's best for pupils what are the best
interventions where there's the most
evidence that goes to show this is going
to have the biggest impact on children
and what we're delivering is
forgive me forgive me look i i hate
shouty
argumentative interviews i really do but
it would be really helpful if you could
answer the question
which is if he says he you know to
implement what needs to be implemented
you need 15 billion pounds why is that
money not coming forward
did you fight for that money have you
been told you can't have that money
what's going on
well what we're doing is we're building
up a whole set of interventions
including the 1.7 billion pounds that's
already been committed
complemented by 1.4 billion pounds these
are all measures that are going to have
a direct
impact on children they're going to have
a direct impact in terms of actually the
amount of tutoring children are going to
be able to get
this is far too long been for preserve
of those who have
been the wealthiest and only been able
to afford it
we're making sure that that's expanded
so all children are able to benefit
but we recognize there's more work to be
done this is part of a process
and this is why we're launching for
review in terms of how we can best
support
children in terms of their schooling and
one of those elements
is about time is there extra time that
is required for children to be able to
be able to be in the classroom not just
for study
but also for enrichment activity as well
and that's
what we're undertaking to do but if
that's so important why hasn't that
happened an extra half hour on the
school day was what was being
sort of touted yesterday that hasn't
come about
i mean that would be at least something
which was a universal approach which did
affect all children why has that not
happened you wanted that didn't you
so what we've recognized is that we want
to bring forward the interventions that
we can deliver
most rapidly for most children and
ensure that actually
we're able to have this hitting the road
as quickly as possible
we've already started the expansion of a
tutoring regime
they're aiming to get quarter of a
million children signed up to it
but we want to take that further that
was one of those things and one of those
measures that we're able to
implement and start delivering from
september
and it's important that we continue to
do that on the
teacher development we are expanding
career frameworks so those
teachers i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry to
interrupt
but you you've mentioned tutoring a few
times brought about in september
getting that implemented only a few
weeks ago nick gibb the school's
minister
said that the number of children
currently getting tutoring was one
percent of pupils
and this is part of a reason as to why
we're expanding our such a tutoring
program
we're on course to have signed up by the
end of this year
quarter of a million pupils but what
we're recognizing is we want to do more
we want to take that to more pupils we
want to see up to six million
children across our school system be
able to benefit from that and be able
to be in the classroom benefiting from
small group group tutoring
we're seeing uh you know the evidence
goes to show
that this delivers real help to children
it goes and sort of
helps them catch up in the learning
they've lost so
children who have maybe found themselves
falling up to two months behind as a
result of a pandemic
as a result of these sessions can catch
up to between either
three and five months of lost learning
it really does
how many times you say the six million
pupils been affected by all of this
you're hoping to step up the tutoring to
250
000 i mean that in itself is a drop in
the ocean
sorry you misheard me actually there
because there's 250 as part of the
current scheme that we're aiming to have
250
000 pupils signed up by the end of this
academic year
but what we're doing as a result of this
extra money is stepping that up
so it's going to be able to impact and
benefit up to 6 million pupils right
across
england that's the scale of expansion
of this program because it works it
delivers results for children
it is what actually not just children
are wanting but
parents are wanting as well because
they're seeing the results
and that's why we're expanding it so
massively uh compared to where it's been
at
because the evidence when you go into
schools when you talk to children who
are benefiting from this tutoring
you're hearing from them about how it's
helping them catch up on their maths
how is helping them better understand
their english
it's giving them that advantage in order
to be able to claw back that time
and that's why we've wanted to take it
away you know expand it from
not just the quarter of a million pupils
that are going to be benefiting it from
this year
but expand it massively next year so
that
millions more are going to be able to
benefit from it i mean
if you're passionate about the the
the need for children to to get this
time
back if you like to recoup the losses
that they've had over the past 16 months
how hard did you actually push at the
treasury
to get the money that you needed
well all the time you're in discussions
right across government
but what's great is that actually both
prime minister and the chancellor
and everyone is committed to making sure
that we take the actions that are needed
in order to be able to help children
benefit that's why we've
continuously brought forward multiple
packages of money you know over three
billion pounds that we're investing in
catch up we've already announced so far
yeah but we are but if everyone if
everyone's so committed
why why are you only announcing today
ten percent of the money that your own
catch-up
tsar says you should have been
announcing today
what we're announcing is a package of
money and
actions that are going to be able to
yeah but why is it only
when they're coming back to school in
the next sort of few weeks
i mean it's it's a it's a pretty
straight it's a pretty straight question
and i'm sorry to keep interrupting i
hate
interrupting it's only 10
of the money that sir kevin collins says
you should have been announcing today
so why is that
so the reason that we're announcing this
package of money because these are
measures that can be deliverable
in the next academic year the measures
that are going to be able to benefit all
children
that's why we announced for 700 million
pounds just
just a few months ago that's why we
announced a billion pounds
in the summer of last year because
they're measures that are able to have
an impact on children
immediately that's been our focus of
making sure that we deliver for children
straight away that's what we're going to
continue to do and the tutoring
has the biggest single impact in terms
of children's attainment
what they're able to deliver children
want it parents want it
and actually we're delivering it on a
scale that's never been
seen before and it is a true revolution
in terms of what we're delivering for
our schools and
and you know a 1.4 billion pound package
you know is an important step in terms
of actually
ensuring children benefit in a very real
way
in terms of being able to pick up this
extra tutoring in the classroom
minister good to talk to you thank you
thank you for having me
well sort of come on the program labor
has been very quick to criticize
that education catch up plan the party
releasing its own proposals today so
we'll talk to the shadow education
secretary
kate green at 20 past eight
future threats oxford and cambridge
researchers spell out some of the
gravest
dangers faced by the uk including
biological weapons and the misuse of
a.i we'll talk about that at a quarter
to eight
at half past eight we'll talk to
ryanair's boss michael o'leary as he
calls on the transport secretary
to open international travel from all eu
countries
now the health secretary will be among
speakers at a global vaccine confidence
summit hosted by the uk
later on today it's going to tackle
misinformation
particularly in countries where there
are high levels of hesitancy
towards the covid jab a global a global
survey from
earlier this year conducted by imperial
college london and ugar have asked
people in a number of countries
if they would take a vaccine in the uk
81
said they would get the jab but some
countries showed weaker confidence
france was just
44 japan 46
well the social media giants have been
accused of not doing enough to tackle
misinformation on the
vaccine heidi larson the director of
vaccine confidence at the
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine says more needs to be
understood about the issue
sometimes there's a disproportionate
focus on misinformation
and not enough attention on the
underlying factors of why people are
believing it
and i think some of the reasons is we're
not giving a compelling enough
alternative fact full uh
story that's relevant to people's lives
the daughter-in-law of conservative peer
lord ashcroft has been
charged with manslaughter by negligence
after a police superintendent was shot
dead in belize
jasmine harton the partner of michael
ashcroft's son
has been denied bayer well let's talk to
our reporter melania veselinovich
and what more do we know about
her well-being and her location at the
moment
well it's thought that she was denied
bail because the police were worried she
might pose a flight risk because of her
canadian citizenship
we know that she had now been
transported from the holiday
town of san pedro to the mainland to the
police
central prison and we can see the video
there of her being escorted from the
local police station
onto the back of a golf buggy she was
handcuffed
but she was allowed to place that bag on
her lap which
concealed her handcuffs now
what is quite appointing here is that
the prison where she's been taken to
is one with some of the harshest
conditions
in the world it featured in the netflix
documentary series inside the world's
toughest prisons we've heard reports
that roman prisoners like jasmine
harting there
are sometimes housed in the same cell as
convicted murderers we've heard reports
about
filthy conditions inside the cells that
are sometimes
overrun by cockroaches and this couldn't
be more than a world away from what
jasmine harting
lifestyle is she is employed in luxury
hotels she is the daughter-in-law
of a prominent tory donor and now her
lawyers are urgently seeking
a supreme court hearing to try to free
her
okay milena thank you security forces in
myanmar have been accused of
premeditated attacks on protesters since
the country's military coup
now in exclusive interviews from a
secret location
three men who defected from the security
forces have told us
they were encouraged to open fire our
southeast asia correspondent siobhan
robbins reports
resistance is growing in a safe house in
myanmar
once police saw soldiers now these men
plan to fight the forces they used to
serve
just talking to us is a huge risk
defectors can be
punished with death in hiding faces and
voices disguised for protection
they explain why they defied the junta
we were told that
we could shoot the protester if they
gather
in more than five we could arrest them
and shoot them we were ordered to shoot
but we couldn't do it
while a shoot to kill policy has never
been officially confirmed
the defectors claim they were encouraged
to open fire
[Applause]
we contacted the junta about the
allegations in this report
it hasn't responded
my friend said if they shoot the
protesters
they will get a promotion as a reward
and be praised for being brave and
following the junior's order
[Applause]
[Music]
shoot just shoot
this is my order um just how
they ordered the troops
if we did not follow the order
we will be punished
as well as the shootings the military's
accused of
other abuses
abuses of power of people of their duty
to protect people are calling soldiers
military talks and also
accusing them of rape let me tell you
yes
um we have seen those scenes at the
front line
i was not involved in it the officers
were calling the women
here and there and abusing them
rape as well it's happening
so now the institutions they once swore
an oath to
are the enemy they must defeat their
freedom has been sacrificed
families left behind
since the coup some protesters have
traveled to rebel areas for training
the defectors will join their fight for
democracy
those who are not familiar with the
military training
they need to learn how to use the
weapons fix them
and stop them i want to teach them
i will join this revolution till the end
i'll give my life i'll kill them
wherever i see them
so in secret they plan they train
they get strong preparing to strike back
against the generals they followed for
so long
siobhan robbins sky news in bangkok
we're looking at the other headlines for
you this morning and six people
including a 13 year old boy have been
arrested in connection with a fatal
stabbing in birmingham
which one resident described as a
horrible situation
police are investigating the murder of a
14 year old boy who was attacked by up
to seven people
in the king standing area of birmingham
paramedics excuse me to be fitted with
body cameras in a bid to prevent
thousands of attacks on frontline staff
each year according to officials
nhs data shows the number of assaults on
frontline staff has increased by 32
percent
over the last five years a new
uk task force will help stop child
sexual abuse images being shared online
analysts from the internet watch
foundation will grade and create
digital fingerprints of millions of
illegal images
sharing these with tech companies to
prevent them being circulated
nearly three hundred thousand pieces of
potentially illegal material was
identified online
last year the worst year on record
a new list of species under threat from
climate change has been revealed
a report by the world wildlife
federation says their
future of certain creatures like snow
leopards and puffins depends on the
outcome
of the cop 26 summit in november
jemima walker reports
leatherback turtles in the depths of the
ocean
snow leopards in the heights of the
himalayas
and puffins on the coast of the uk
these are just some of the animals whose
habitats are being ravaged by global
warming
the wwf says the government must use
cop26
to make tangible pledges to protect the
planet
they will have to work with the treasury
and all the ministries to say look
any commitment any investments you make
as we go through this green recovery
are not contrary to the commitments we
make for climate
let's be really clear in the last 10 15
20 has been littered with
promises and commitments many of which
have not been seen through
as antarctic temperatures rise
populations of emperor penguins continue
to drop
unlike the humboldt penguins here at
chessington zoo
the emperor relies on frosty
temperatures
as the sea ice is melting it's reducing
the space for emperor penguins to nest
and to breed
and but then it also means that their
predators can encroach closer on them so
there's less spaces for them to get away
from those predators
with that sea ice melting the squirrel
monkey is another endangered species
their natural habitat is a very small
part of the amazon rainforest and
they're crucial
in maintaining biodiversity but rising
flood levels and temperatures could mean
their entire habitat is destroyed
we would love nothing more than our
guests to be able to go out to the
amazon and see
these incredible species but
unfortunately at the rate that they're
declining the only place
that they may be able to see them is
here at the zoo
the wwf says a very human response is
needed to save these treasured species
they hope cop 26 in november will
provide an opportunity
to set the wheels in motion jemima
walker sky news
well the top story this morning and the
government has announced an additional
1.4 billion pounds of funding for a
catch-up program
for school children in england the plan
was drawn up by sir kevin collins
appointed as the government's
covid catch-up czar in april but reports
suggest to kevin
requested 10 times the funding which has
been allocated
so i spoke to the education secretary
just a few minutes ago
you appointed sir sir kevin collins as
the catch-up czar
i mean do you trust him do you agree
with him
so so we've been working incredibly
closely at all stages
forgive me that's a that's that's a very
straightforward question
do you trust him do you believe in what
he's trying to achieve
yes or no absolutely and these are why
the interventions
this is why the interventions he says
he says you need 15 billion pounds
you've given him 1.4 in this 1.7 earlier
on as you say
but he says you need 15 billion if you
trust him if you absolutely agree with
him
why isn't he getting that money
so what we've been doing is working with
sir kevin on a
whole package of measures one of those
is the expansion
of our tutoring program there's a
billion pounds going into that
the other key element of uh that
expansion and sort of support
for schools and children is actually
through teacher quality as well
that's why we're committing 400 million
pounds to
early years and driving up teacher
quality because actually
these are interventions that we've
worked on together and actually this is
why
we're organizing a review in terms of
time in terms of
how we look at expanding time what is
best for schools but most importantly
what's best for pupils well let's talk
to the general secretary of the
association of school and college
leaders jeff barton
good to see you this morning what do you
make of this plan
oh it's pretty dispiriting steve isn't
it here i am as somebody who's leading a
trade union and
all my colleagues it feels this morning
as if we have got
higher ambitions of the nation's
children and young people then the
education secretary it's
pretty pitiful isn't it only yesterday
we were hearing stories about extending
the school day and even if some people
disagreed with it at least there was a
sense of
let's do something radical let's do
something different today's announcement
essentially equates to 50 pounds per
head you compare that with
the usa which is putting 1600 pounds per
head
per young person the netherlands two and
a half thousand pounds per head
so what is it about those children in
the netherlands or the usa
that makes them worth more than our
education secretary our government
seems to say it's time to stop the
rhetoric i think and start the action on
behalf of children and young people
well it's interesting you mentioned the
longer school days we certainly got the
impression
that the education secretary would have
liked to have
longer school days but perhaps he's been
blocked one way or another from
from doing that but i mean you as a
union you're not particularly in favor
of that are you
oh well we we as a union have got the
best motto in the world we speak on
behalf of members we act
on behalf of children and young people
and you know what there is at the heart
of the announcement today
uh stephen isn't just something
disappointing in financial terms
it's actually disappointing in terms of
the ambition about what education is
about and what it's for and what what i
know
as being an english teacher 32 years and
a head teacher of 15 years
is the idea that 15 hours of extra maths
is the solution at the end of a global
pandemic is just pitiful it's woeful
that that actually if what you could do
after school is to make sure that the
kind of activities that i'm guessing
gavin williamson and the chancellor used
to have routinely at their schools
that is all the extracurricular
commitment to the arts
to sport as well as tuition so that was
the norm
for them why should that not be an
entitlement to every child
of every background particularly on the
watch of a government that says it's
going to level up for those communities
today is the day i think we'll look back
on and think why is it
that when we could find so much money
for so many other projects
the future of our nation in terms of our
young people we're not worth investing
in properly
i mean you you say 15 billion pounds i
mean
to be fair that's what sir kevin collins
has recommended but but what would that
other 90 percent be used for what i mean
how would that directly affect the
education
and the the catch-up of these young
people well i think the most
expensive part of all of this is if you
decide that you are going to do
something
around the school day so if you were
truly ambitious you might say what would
it look like if schools were to start at
eight in the morning
and to finish at 5 30 in the evening and
that became the new norm
the teachers focus on what they do in
the classroom because we know that's the
number one
ingredient so we welcome today the fact
there is a commitment to more teacher
training that's a good
thing but wouldn't that then allow you
to employ other specialists who could
help with mental health issues where we
know there is a crisis for too many
young people
that you could bring in sports coaches
after school that you could have
the richness of of culture and the arts
after school
not just because you're either paying
for it or lucky enough to go to a school
that can afford it
but because we see it as a national
entitlement and that would give a sense
of coming out of a crisis
with a much greater sense of ambition
and yes it would cost
but it seems to us that the cost of not
doing all of this of young people
not in the future getting the
qualifications and then the jobs they
need
is a much more deep-rooted longer-term
one
and shame on us if we don't really
embrace the opportunity to do something
better
look a lot of people watching i i will
probably be thinking at least
at least some people watching and
whether the taxpayers paying for this
are going to think well why spend money
on on arts and and sport when actually
these kids need to
be learning maths and english
oh and it's it's not an either or i mean
i i know as a head teacher i
used to go under pressure from some of
the staff actually saying we think that
this young person should be taken out of
their pe lessons or their music lessons
to do extra maths
i i think that's a misguided view it's
not always about quantity
it's about the quality of the teaching
so let's free the teachers up to do that
and you know what i saw is that young
people who were taking part in
extracurricular activities
often did better in the classroom and
you only have to look to our great
independent schools where that has been
the great tradition that you do better
in your maths exam because you're doing
better playing hockey or whatever it is
that has been a proud tradition and this
could have been an opportunity to say
that enrichment costs
but the cost of not doing this is
long-term and deeply damaging for our
young people
jeff barton good to talk to you thank
you thank you steven
let's talk to our political
correspondent tamara cohen who's in
westminster what do you think tomorrow
well a lot of people in the education
world not very happy about this
announcement
they say it was much trailed as the way
to help school children who've
lost out so much over the past year try
to catch up there was all sorts of ideas
knocking around particularly from
sir kevin collins a former head teacher
who boris johnson hired
back in february to advise on this he at
the time talked about a longer school
day doing more sports and music
and so on none of that is in here it's
all about tutoring
which a lot of people say is an approach
that evidence shows
does work and that it could be extended
to millions of people it's been pretty
slow
to start so far but even if it was
extended to six million pupils
that would only be about five hours a
year each because this is over three
years so many in the education world
saying where's the rest of it
okay tomorrow thank you now yesterday
marked a hundred years since as many as
300 african americans were murdered in
the american city of tulsa
president biden went to the site to mark
one of the worst episodes of racial
violence in american history and he's
the
first president to take part in the
memorial as michelle clifford reports
within 24 hours the community would be
completely destroyed at the hands of
thousands of white riders
it was a massacre a century on and a
president grappling with today's racial
tensions in america
traveled to tulsa to confront the past
being told the horrific detail
of one of the darkest but largely
overlooked moments
in this country's history he came to
remember those who died but also to
promise change
saying the battle for racial equality in
america is far from over
for much too long the history of what
took place here was told
in silence cloaked in darkness
but just because history is silent it
doesn't mean that it did not take place
and while darkness can hide much it
erases
nothing it erases nothing
greenwood known as black wall street was
a prosperous african-american community
a century ago
where on the night of may the 31st white
rioters gunned down residents
and set fire to homes block by block
after a black man was accused of
assaulting a white girl
an estimated 300 people were killed and
thousands left homeless
leslie benningfield was a child of six
that night
the memories for her are still vivid but
painful to recall
the soldiers were coming in to run the
rebels out
and uh everybody was running and hiding
and trying to get away
i don't know it's just it's just a big
mess
only now are many discovering what
happened in this part of the usa a
century ago
and demands are being made for
reparations for greenwood
the events of that night were long
suppressed were not taught in schools
and even those who lived through the
horror found it hard to speak about
the truth of it truly needs to come out
so that real healing can happen
so that there are so many that are still
bound to that incident
and what it meant and what it took away
that they can't move on into what they
can have
and create part of that healing may come
for some families if they're finally
able to lay their ancestors to rest
mass graves from the massacre are being
excavated in the hope of identifying the
bodies
this taking place a century after so
many died
and at a time of racial reckoning in
america
michelle clifford sky news washington
oxford and cambridge researchers are
warning of future
extreme risks greater than kovid 19.
in a report published today they're
calling on the government not to fight
the last war
but prepare for the risks of the future
now or one of the authors of the report
is toby ord
good to see you this morning i mean what
are the risks we need to be looking at
yes uh we think that the the key risks
that the government should be focusing
on
now are to do with biosecurity uh more
generally than uh than covert
uh new pandemics uh that are naturally
arising uh but also to prepare for
bio weapons or uh lab escapes uh from
dangerous research
uh and to prepare for uh the dangers
that ai could pose as it continues to
develop
okay let's talk biosecurity to begin
with them i mean what what do we mean
by biosecurity well
in the same way that we need to protect
people with national security
we need to protect the citizens of the
uk and the wider world
from biological threats um these threats
could come from nature but they could
also come from other countries or from
terrorist groups
why do we think they're likely to pose a
more of a threat in the future
well the the threat that they pose uh is
increasing as the technology around them
increases
we've had these dramatic breakthroughs
in biotechnology over recent decades
and things that were only achievable by
the very top scientists in the world
uh two years later are being done in
science competitions
by very bright students so there's more
and more actors who have the ability to
create
uh dangerous threats if they so choose
so how do we even begin to
think of of protecting against that then
if this is all becoming
more and more commonplace it is
extremely difficult
uh and the main thing we're saying is
that it warrants substantially more
attention
uh the uk needs to spend millions to
save billions in this case to kind of
take out an insurance policy against
these types of risks
but an example with biosecurity in
particular is to
have a prize to improve developments in
meta-genomic sequencing
this is where you sequence all the dna
and rna
in a sample from a patient and then you
can find even if there is a completely
novel pathogen
that science has never seen before you
can detect that against the database
uh if this had been done in wuhan uh
then we would have known that there was
something that was
most similar to sars but different to
anything that we knew
uh on day one okay look when it comes to
ai
i mean scientists have warned against ai
for
for quite a long time but on the basis
that artificial intelligence as we call
it doesn't actually exist yet
is that a fair assessment yeah there's
dramatic progress in ai at the moment
and it's
increasing uh as we speak uh but we
don't know exactly how far it will go
there's still a lot of disagreement
uh although many scientists within
artificial intelligence
uh believe that in the next few decades
uh we'll reach the point uh where
ai abilities surpass human level but
there are problems that we have to be
concerned about before that point
and then different kinds of problems
after
such as well in the uh the near term
at the moment there are extremely good
text generation systems
uh that if you tell it a topic it can
produce vast amounts of text on that
uh that or things that modify video to
uh to show
uh public figures doing things they
didn't really do are examples of things
that could be dangerous uh in terms of
propaganda or could swing an election
yeah and another example for the uk in
particular
is that it would be very dangerous if we
were to uh include
ai systems inside our nuclear command
and control
and communications uh systems i mean
part of the issue we look at
ai more widely is the idea that once
something actually does develop its own
intelligence that they're just going to
learn such is it right
they would learn at such an exponential
rate that they would just surpass us
within
months or years that is a very live
uh concern and a theory it's not clear
what would happen maybe it would plateau
uh at a level below ours or or perhaps
just uh slightly above vowels
but we need to take seriously the
possibility uh that things could go
wrong
uh and to invest more uh given how many
people's lives and livelihoods are at
stake
toby good to talk to you this morning
thank you thank you